mesdames et messieurs s'il vous plaît je
vous demandais un moment d'attention
rarissime en effet de voir une pouliche
avec un tel pedigree aux ventes de
yearlings de deauville
d'ordinaire ces chevaux se vendent
plutôt en privé imaginez fille de
motivateur et de trévise petite soeur de
trêve
cette police n'est chez les aides en
mars 2014 n'a pas encore montré ce
qu'elle sait faire qu'elle est déjà une
star elle est belle physiquement elle
alla de jolies choses à faire valoir
mais vous dire que ça va faire une
championne c'est un peu tôt quand même
encore un peu tôt et pourtant la mise à
prix du lot 176 s'élève à 500 mille
euros
le ring est bondé celles qui portent
offrant les toiles de son père et de sa
soeur devait être le clou de la vente
arqana cette année mais les enchères
comme les courses ne sont jamais joué
d'avancé
et comme sa grande soeur en 2011 la
pouliche n'a pas trouvé preneur au prix
espéré
elle après la fin de son prix de réserve
donc pour la gare vous êtes déçu pas du
tout pas du tout parce que je suis ravi
de la garde et dont il faut absolument
pas déçu c'était quoi le prix de réserve
ça ça vous regarde pas je suis désolé
mais c'est pas de genre de choses on
peut dire parce qu'on ne sait pas il ya
peut-être des gens qui vont venir nous
offrir de l'argent de temps en temps
quand les cheveux sont pas vendus dans
le ring il ya des gens qui viennent les
acheter à l'amiable
donc je peux pas vous dire le prix de
réserve la presse spécialisée a évoqué
la somme de 2 millions d'euros et la
pouliche est toujours au haras du
quesnay pour le plus grand plaisir de
christiane head on est obligé de les
vendre
il faut faire tourner et loire nous on
hamm est pas là de gaieté de coeur bien
sûr que si on avait les moyens de la
garde et on la garde ray mais une jument
comme ça c'est difficile à garder parce
qu'elle va permettre pour nous elle va
permettre de réinvestir d'acheter des
courants de sang un petit peu différent
et donc c'est ce que l'on cherche
et puis on a la mer il faut pas
l'oublier on a des soeurs aussi la mère
est jeune mère à 11 ans elle va encore
produire donc on aura l'occasion encore
d'avoir des soeurs de crève puisque en
principe elle va retourner à motivateur
l'année prochaine donc voilà c'est la
vie une jument cent vingt et une autres
arrivent c'est la loi des courses trêve
rentrera au haras à la fin du mois et sa
petite soeur arrivera à l'entraînement
en novembre chez christiane est bien sûr
la police n'est pas encore baptisé mais
son nom commencera par un thé comme sa
mère et sa soeur
la lettre porte bonheur des aides dans
la famille heads et à la maman de
christiane et de freddy épouse d'alec
qu'il incombe entre autres de trouver
les noms des chevaux car les aides c'est
une dynastie autant qu'une tribu et
c'est ce que nous vous raconterons de 20